the corrupt lying rage and hate-filled
medium mob they're at it again spinning
in circles for the last 24 straight
hours they have again breathlessly
hysterically been echoing a report from
The Washington Post claiming that this
unknown person from the Intel community
allegedly allegedly filed the
whistleblower complaint about a
troubling promise that President Trump
made to another world leader on the
phone so did he promise to send the
president Trump promised to send
billions of free fuel and nuclear
infrastructure to North Korea no wait a
minute that's what President Bill
Clinton did did he promise to give 150
billion in in cash and other currencies
to the mullahs of Iran no that was
President Obama did he promise to be
more flexible with Vladimir after the
election but don't tell the American
people mr. Medvedev that I'm gonna be
more flexible just told my buddy
Vladimir that was President Obama too it
was actually all caught on tape
[Music]
I understand I transmit to Vladimir you
know this letter you know about the
compromising materials yes but but of
course naked pics and Trump is that
crazy they all are so weak let's recap
here we have Roswell Rachel Maddow yes
America's number one psycho conspiracy
theorist and all of our fellow Russia
Russia Russia and Peach impeach impeach
collusion collusion stormy stormy
obsessed conspiracy theorists in the
media mob they really seem to care at
all about Obama's promise to Vladimir or
Clinton's promise to North Korea or the
money that they dumped on the mullahs in
Iran but that will run wall-to-wall
coverage about it at best a nebulous
story where we don't know the identity
of the whistleblower we don't know any
details of the allegations we don't know
which world leader was referenced nobody
has the clue what the so-called promise
was naturally nobody else in the media
that is now echoing what the Washington
Post says ever decided to independently
verify these unknown claims on their own
that this unknown individual is making
so tonight the Washington Post is adding
to their unknown report that the
whistleblowers complaint involves the
country of Ukraine now I was happy at
this news maybe they will give us
information that they said that they
want to give us that we have not taken
yet about their influence in the 2016
election to help Hillary Clinton and or
maybe they're going to tell us oh why
they really gave in to Joe Biden's
pressure basically leveraging a billion
of our taxpayer dollars here's what we
also know we do know that key facts
details don't matter to this mob there's
media mob Rush Limbaugh pointed out you
can tell these people any single thing
you want they'll report it verbatim so
long as it can be used to smear Trump it
goes like this one Network reports a
salacious story no sources no specifics
and every other outlet they repeat it
and they get all whipped up into a
frenzy it's like a circular firing squad
this network up of themselves only now
that's what we saw today
what is a a rage psychotic level
speculation hysteria on nearly every
single solitary network over what is one
sketchy story with no details no
specifics from bezos's Washington Post
hour after hour after hour and it's
exactly what the vengeful Trump haters
in the deep state wanted it fits a
pattern after all this is not the first
leak on Donald Trump from the Intel
community that was designed to smear
president Trump remembered just a few
days ago when the media mob they went
crazy about that report that a
high-level US spy had to be extracted
from Moscow because President Trump
couldn't be trusted with secret
information well that turned out to be a
more fake news the spy was actually
extracted because of reasons unrelated
at all to President Trump that dated
back to the Obama administration and the
real reason for the extraction turned
out to be well nothing to do with Trump
know the extraction was due to the media
coverage they put the guy's life in
jeopardy that after the story breaks and
the guys back here all the media did
everything in their power to expose not
only the person's identity but pretty
much give Vladimir Putin the guys home
address which would be a clear and
present danger to him and his family so
it's now perfectly clear that as
president Trump dismantles and exposes
the deep state many bureaucrats who hate
him they will do nothing to destroy his
presidency by the way how did they get
this information let's not forget the
chilling comment see that senator from
New York Chuckie Schumer in 2017 you
miss you mess with the Intel community
they've got six ways from Sunday to get
back at you really is that what they're
gonna do with the powerful tools of
intelligence we give them get back at us
look you take on the intelligence
community they have six ways from Sunday
at getting back at you so even for a
practical supposedly hard-nosed
businessman he's being really dumb to do
this they have six ways and Sunday to
get back to you so we're going to give
them the most powerful tools of
intelligence to protect us then they're
gonna turn that weaponry on us or any
president they don't like now we know
members of the Intel community under
President Obama we already know
they spied on president Trump's
associates and gasses campaign is
transition and presidency we know about
the informants and undercover agents the
outsourcing of intelligence to our
allies to circumvent US laws while we
also know that they are not happy the
president Trump's some of them the very
small minority exposing their gross
misconduct so with each and every leak
each every so-called bombshell report
was seeing a very petty attempt at
revenge six ways from Sunday from only a
few bad actors who hate the president
and like Groundhog Day the medium of
hate the president they buy it all hook
line sinker with no facts at all